[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Marie-Hélène Aubert
vice-présidente délégué à l'autonomie à
la coopération décentralisée bonjour
alors on va parler ensemble du nouveau
programme de soutien au développement de
l'habitat spécifique ou adapté dans dans
les Yvelines avant cela quelles sont les
objectifs en quels sont vos objectifs et
ambitions en termes d'habitat
ça fait des années que le département
accompagne les communes qui souhaitent
produire du logement accompagnent la
production de logements dans le
département
il continue il accentue cette politique
aujourd'hui parce que dans un contexte
aujourd'hui où le le il est difficile de
produire douloureusement du logement en
raison des coûts en raison de l'accès
aux fonciers voilà puis aujourd'hui les
habitants sont de plus en plus souvent
opposés à la construction de de nouveaux
logements donc c'est difficile donc le
département vient en appui aux communes
pour produire du logement il s'agit
aussi de pouvoir
rééquilibrer un petit peu la production
de logements sur le tout le territoire
du département des Yvelines on a
aujourd'hui 60 communes qui sont
carencées au titre de la loi SR1 qui
n'ont pas produit leur quota de logement
et Serru et puis on a des quartiers
prioritaires en grand nombre aussi une
trentaine je crois qui ont besoin aussi
d'appui pour la production de logements
neufs il s'agit d'appuyer donc les les
communes mais aussi les bailleurs
sociaux qui ont des programmes
particuliers notamment sur l'habitat
spécifique alors vous l'avez dit depuis
2006 le département encourage le
développement de l'habitat de l'habitat
spécifique et qu'est-ce qu'un habitat
spécifique qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire c'est pas l'habitat qui
est spécifique c'est le public
ça s'adresse à des à des publics qui
sont soit des jeunes actifs soit qui
sont ciblesses sur des populations
précises soit des étudiants soit des
seigneurs autonomes soit des publics qui
sont en situation d'exclusion et qu'il
faut remettre en selle par un logement
d'abord et voilà donc c'est ce public là
qui sont particulièrement ciblées au
travers d'un dispositif qui s'appelle
Yvelines résidence qui existe depuis
2015 ou 2016 je crois dans ma commune
j'ai fait le premier le premier
réalisation de Yvelines résidence en
2016 une pension de famille justement
pour pour bien comprendre ce programme
de soutien au développement de l'habitat
spécifique se tourne vers les
établissements qui souhaitent développer
ce genre d'habitat ou est-ce que c'est
vers les collectivités c'est d'abord
vers les vers les collectivités c'est un
appui le dispositif d'une résidence un
appui au collectivités avant tout c'est
un contrat qui est signé entre les
intercommunalités et le département sur
la base d'un diagnostic qui a été fait
sur ce qui était nécessaire sur le
territoire de l'intercommunalité et
après ça on déploie ces programmes et
obligatoirement il y a une construction
ou est-ce que ça peut être aussi des
bâtiments qui sont rénovés justement
pour ces habitats spécifiques
à rénover bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est
des petits en général c'est des petites
c'est des petits structures enfin c'est
voilà dans un communiqué de presse vous
vous indiquez notamment que le programme
donc Yvelines résidence qui met en
oeuvre ce soutien au développement de
l'habitat spécifique dans le département
a été une réponse positive pour les
étudiants notamment mais soulever un
problème au niveau des personnes
précaires et les seniors autonomes qui
n'ont pas toujours les moyens justement
de se loger quel problème se pose à
l'heure où nous nous échangeons pour ces
pour ces publics
pour les étudiants vous l'avez dit on a
réalisé près de 3000 plus de 3000 places
je crois pour les étudiants donc on a
des gens en partie répondu pour les pour
les publics en situation d'exclusion ce
sont des pensions de famille qui sont
voilà peut-être moins prisés par les
communes mais c'est vrai qu'on continue
à encourager ce genre de de réalisation
j'en ai une dans ma commune ça
fonctionne très très bien c'est vraiment
venez faire un sujet un jour sur ma
maison intergénérationnelle pension de
famille et puis sur les seniors
autonomes il y a aussi des programmes et
il y a peut-être en parler dans un
instant de l'habitat inclusif qui est
déployé dans un autre dispositif qui est
un dispositif d'État dans lequel on
s'est inscrit l'habitat inclusif pour
pouvoir accueillir des
personnes âgées ou les personnes en
situation de handicap dans des petites
structures si on vit comme chez soi mais
on vit pas seul alors le Département
souhaite la création de 2000 places dans
les habitats spécifiques parmi elles 900
places seront à destination des publics
en situation de grande précarités
sociaux économiques des familles
monoparentales des victimes de violence
intrafamiliales donc c'est également un
sujet que que le département prend à
cœur finalement de d'accueillir ces
publics et des personnes en situation de
handicap pourquoi il vous semble
nécessaire de vous concentrer sur ces
publics et notamment par exemple les les
victimes de violences intrafamiliales
mais toutes ces personnes là sont des
publics cibles du département c'est les
gens qu'on accompagne au quotidien qu'on
accompagne socialement et pouvoir offrir
une solution de logements à des publics
là qui sont souvent en difficulté c'est
sa réponse à aux politiques
départementales sociales d'autonomie etc
pour ces publics 500 places seront
également dédiées au Seigneur autonome
et 600 à destination des jeunes actifs
et étudiants les seigneurs et les
étudiants on l'a dit il y a un instant
peine aujourd'hui à trouver un logement
adapté à leurs besoins c'est un constat
que vous avez malheureusement fait
également dans le département des
Yvelines
sont aujourd'hui souhaitent vieillir à
domicile mais parfois ça devient un
petit peu quand le logement est pas
adapté ça devient difficile pas pour
autant qu'on a envie d'aller dans un
EHPAD seulement trois personnes et 3%
des personnes âgées souhaitent vieillir
dans un EHPAD donc il faut trouver des
solutions intermédiaires pour pouvoir
accueillir ces seniors autonomes qui ne
veulent qui ne peuvent plus vivre dans
un pavillon trop lourd à entretenir mais
qui sont encore autonomes pour éviter
les pads qui qui n'est pas qui est
médicalisé et dont ils n'ont pas besoin
et donc pour ces donc seniors autonomes
mais également pour pour les personnes
en situation de handicap donc il existe
le l'habitat spécifique mais également
l'habitat inclusif alors quels sont les
différences justement entre l'habitat
inclusif et l'habitat l'habitat
spécifique alors l'habitat spécifique
c'est une politique départementale
clairement l'habitat inclusif est une
politique d'État qui vise à développer
des petites structures de 8 à 15
personnes maximum deux colocations
d'habitats partagés insérer accompagner
et où on est suffisamment autonome pour
ne pas être dans un établissement mais
pas complètement pour vivre tout seul
donc vivre à plusieurs en étant
accompagné et être chez soi avoir choisi
de vivre comme ça déjà parce que
une personne en situation de handicap ou
une personne âgée on est souvent on vous
laisse pas le choix on vous dit bah tu
vas dans un établissement parce qu'il y
a pas d'autres solutions aujourd'hui on
travaille plus dans la dentelle on veut
pouvoir accompagner davantage ces
personnes qui sont ni complètement
dépendantes ni suffisamment autonome
pour être dans un logement seul est-ce
que justement c'est seniors ou c'est ces
personnes en situation de handicap sont
les deux seuls publics finalement visés
par le par l'habitat inclusif oui oui
que les personnes âgées et les personnes
en situation de handicap on développe la
250 places pour pour ses habitats là et
justement donc vous l'avez évoqué il y a
un instant la solution la plus simple
pour pour les familles des seniors en
général c'est d'inscrire les seigneurs
dans un établissement spécialisé pour
personnes âgées les EHPAD pourquoi ce
dispositif de l'habitat inclusif peut
être considéré comme une solution
positive pour ce public est-ce que
justement l'inclusion ne permet pas
également une lutte contre la solitude
ça permet de nuque contre la solitude
mais dans un EHPAD vous n'êtes pas seul
non plus c'est une solution
intermédiaire aujourd'hui les pâtes
doivent se réinventer
c'est très médicalisé on n'est pas or il
y a beaucoup de personnes qui ne sont
plus autonomes pour vivre chez elle
toute seule comme je vous le disais mais
qui ne sont pas aussi
dépendantes que on doit l'être quand on
va dans un EHPAD je prends un exemple
d'une maison qui est à Buc ou au loge il
y en a une autre également qui accueille
huit personnes en situation de maladie
de Alzheimer qui vivent à huit dans une
maison comme si elles étaient chez elles
et elles participent aux travaux
ménagers et elle elle reçoivent comme si
elles étaient chez elles et c'est
magique c'est magique on voit tout de
suite l'amélioration de la situation de
la personne parce que ça n'est pas la
vie en collectivité ça n'est pas des
horaires fixes comme dans une
collectivité d'epad donc c'est quand on
n'a pas besoin
[Musique]
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation pour
en rediscuter dans une prochaine
émission et pour revoir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]